so in this video we're going to talk
about the physics of the stratosphere
and try and explain why it has that
peculiar temperature profile that we saw
it having last time now if you didn't
see that last video if you just like a
refresher then you can click the link up
here now in order to talk about the
stratosphere we asked seemed to start
talking about the Sun now the Sun in
case you haven't noticed is hot like
really really hot it's the source of
almost all energy of all the planets in
the solar system and the earth is no
exception
the way in which the Sun transmits
energy to earth is for a mechanism
called radiation now when most people
think of radiation they think of alpha
beta particles gamma particles or these
and really nasty things that given off
by radioactive sources but what means in
a general physics context is rather
different when we talk about radiation
what we really mean is electromagnetic
radiation or e/m radiation now visible
light is an example of e/m radiation as
the gamma rays I talked about earlier
and also the heat coming off of a fire
they're all forms of electromagnetic
radiation but they're different because
they have different wavelengths
radiation is transmitted from one point
to another as a wave and so has a
wavelength associated with it as well as
an amplitude in exactly the same way
that a water wave has a wavelength and
an amplitude associated with it the
difference with eeehm radiation though
is that while water waves need well
water to move through electromagnetic
radiation doesn't need a substance to
move through it can go through a vacuum
like space and the reason for this is
that it moves its waves through a much
more fundamental medium which is the
electromagnetic field but that's a
discussion for another time the point is
that electromagnetic radiation can have
a whole bunch of different wavelengths
and we display these wavelengths on the
electromagnetic spectrum the Sun
transmits energy at a whole bunch of
different wavelengths and we can
actually see what wavelengths it emits
at by looking at its spectrum and what
we can see by comparing it to the
electromagnetic spectrum is that it
transmits mostly in the ultraviolet and
the thermal bands now this explains why
the Sun appears so hot to us when it's
in the day it feels hot when the Sun
shines on
because it's emitting a lot of thermal
radiation and between thermal and
ultraviolet bands of course is visible
lights why the sun's so bright radiation
is thrown off by the Sun in every
direction and the earth absorbs some of
it now most of that radiation passes
straight through the Earth's atmosphere
and gets absorbed by the planet itself
and by absorbing the energy that was
transmitted by that radiation the earth
heats up and starts to emit radiation of
its own and it's emission profile looks
like this the crucial thing to notice
here is that the earth transmits energy
at longer wavelengths than the Sun does
now this is because long wavelength
radiation carries less energy than short
wavelength radiation and the amount of
energy that an object gives out due to
thermal radiation is proportional to how
hot it is so the Sun is very hot it
emits a lot of energy and so it emits
that energy primarily at shorter
wavelengths where the earth which is
much cooler than the Sun emits less
energy and so transmits it at longer
wavelengths and while the short
wavelength radiation given off by the
Sun passes straight through the
atmosphere from the top down to the
surface the Earth's radiation that gets
emitted which comes from the surface and
goes through the atmosphere and out into
space gets a much rougher treatment
because it turns out that the Earth's
atmosphere is very very good at
absorbing long wavelength radiation now
what determines if a particular
substance is good or bad at absorbing a
particular wavelength of radiation is
rather complex series of interactions
that involves the number of atoms and
the molecule and their electrons but
what's important here is that as you
might remember from the first video 99%
of the earth's atmosphere is o2 and n2
oxygen and nitrogen and both of those
molecules have two atoms apiece and
having two atoms in those molecules
renders them very effective at absorbing
long wavelength radiation this
absorption of the thermal wavelengths
the long wavelength radiation from the
Earth's surface by nitrogen and oxygen
in the atmosphere results in the
atmosphere that is to begin with getting
cooler the high you go due to absorption
of that radiation and then
subsequent slightly weaker real mission
by omitting slightly less radiation than
it absorbs a particular layer in the
atmosphere warm slightly by the first
law of thermodynamics and by attenuating
or reducing subsequently with each layer
the amount of radiation which reaches
higher levels of the atmosphere
there's less energy available to be
converted into thermal energy and so the
atmosphere cools or gets cooler the
higher you go now let's look back at the
temperature profile that we saw in the
first video in the troposphere and the
meters view we see this profile that
we're expecting that the Earth's
atmosphere gets cooler the higher you go
but in the stratosphere we've seen the
exact opposite it's getting warmer so
we're obviously missing something and
we're missing a really important part of
the stratospheric system we're missing
ozone ozone is a molecule formed of
three oxygen atoms and it's found in
huge abundance in the middle
stratosphere though it's by no means the
dominant gas in those areas and the fact
that it's formed of three atoms instead
of the two of nitrogen and oxygen means
that it has different absorption
properties and in particular it means
that it's not so great at absorbing the
long wavelength radiation of the earth
emits but it's really good at absorbing
the short wavelength radiation that the
Sun emits what this means is that the
ozone in the stratosphere absorbs some
of the short wavelength radiation coming
in from the Sun and by the first law of
thermodynamics by doing so it heats up
and by having hot ozone you have warm
air in the rest the stratosphere and
this combined with the rest of the gases
in the stratosphere so the nitrogen and
the oxygen interacting with a long
wavelength radiation from the surface of
the earth combines to form the
temperature profile that we see what we
call a temperature inversion but exactly
how zone absorbs the short wavelength
radiation from the Sun is quite
interesting and it taps into a global
problem from the past century because
the specific short wavelength of
radiation that ozone is very good at
absorbing has another name it's
ultraviolet radiation and the UVB baton
to be specific now UVB is important
because well it
not very good for us and prolonged
exposure to UVB comes on cataracts and
all manner of different cancers and so
the ozone layer is actually a very
important shield for us on the surface
of the planet the ozone layer prevents
this harmful UVB radiation from reaching
the surface and so it's in our best
interest to maintain a healthy ozone
layer that blocks the UVB out but um we
haven't really been doing that for the
most part of the twentieth century
humans have been emitting chemicals
called chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs and
CFCs disrupt the very delicately
balanced cycle by which ozone is created
in the atmosphere called the Chapman
cycle and by doing so it's been
depleting the amount of ozone in the
atmosphere and you might have heard
about this the ozone hole over the South
Pole was of significant cause of concern
because our shield
from harmful radiation was being damaged
and potentially was going to be
destroyed forever
mercifully however in a surprising case
of environmental news being good and not
being reported the ozone layer is
currently healing this is because
various protocols in the late 80s and
early 90s successfully banned production
and emission of CFCs and hopefully
that's going to be a precedent for
future environmental action on a global
scale such as climate change but for now
the ozone in the Earth's atmosphere is
going to be returning to pre-industrial
levels by sometime in the mid 21st
century so in this video we've covered
radiation concepts how energy is emitted
by different objects at different
wavelengths depending on how hot they
are with hotter objects giving off more
energy in the form of short wavelength
radiation we've covered the absorption
of long wavelength radiation by the
nitrogen and oxygen in the Earth's
atmosphere the absorption of short
wavelength radiation by ozone in the
Earth's stratosphere and how humans
nearly messed up that system completely
in the next video we're going to be
looking to the poles to cover the
physics of the scary-sounding
stratospheric polar vortex the single
largest feature in the stratosphere
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a like
and consider subscribing to this channel
for more educational content face
reading indeed
and writing them up in scientific
language called lay tech it's a
scientific typesetting language which
makes up community the audience it's
gonna be what I'll write my thesis it